So let's see if we understand
the relationship between SMT and
cache behavior.
Let's say we have a program named
a whose working set is 10 kilobits.
And we have programs B and
C whose working sets are 4 kilobits and
1 kilobits, respectively.
Let's say our processor supports
four threads simultaneously
SMT fashion and
has an 8 kilobyte data level 1 cache.
In this case, we should run A, B, and
C together because all of
them can run simultaneously.
A and B together,
we could run C simultaneously but
we choose to run it
after we finish A and B.
Or we do A and B for a while,
then C for a while and so on.
So pretty much,
we don't run them simultaneously.
We run C separately from the other two.
And the next option is, we run A without
using the other three SMT ways.
Then, we run B and
C in two of the four SMT ways.
But we don't run A together
with the other two.
The next option is run A and
C together, then B, but don't
do B simultaneously using multithreading
when we are doing A and C.
Or, do them one at a time.
Although we could run four at a time,
we choose to run one at a time.